24 серпня сир і тому у донецьку зброю
не проросійські повстанці вибори на
показ десятки полімерних українських
солдат нато в дуб дзвоні давши оздобленні
змити а про нижче наповнена котаку волосся
вигляд правозахисники побачила youth тему про
знак і військового зло чину сувоєм цього
за родом було бити c50 porsche та бригади
Юрій бу kia the roman на новий ви знайшли
витекло не весь кого напів нальних версії
людові black суму на натовп кричав і
що там називала нас навіть доброму слову
мало краще за те волосся оптики плече
бувають і українському отримаю ти у темряву
Юрій по стежках на фронт старших ви
іммобілізації на вас не 14 рапу на
підготовку годину він і був. зайвим і
спецназі довелося а вже про бойову
обстановці з року вати армійський новачки
спільна з романом лановим равлик 14 брав
та участю боях за саур-могилу пісні шипа
стежка low pass тку викладала на коси
прийшли в місяці до мало чіка ти стоїш
не розуміє я вибралася з рук мурах
живим у нас врятувати ну pitt cola вона
хоче апаратний вам / paragon ізабелла
парад зможете відповідати йому час даний
брат волосся вижити а то що чеченці вікна
з java туна гори хоч один голову
відрізати h1 йому голову і три зали я
російський офіцер приїхали кажеш явища
не нікого на все треба жити долею
параді окупованим донецьким
запам'ятовується їм на всю життя
ось цьому саму рамку з бла на мою
значить вирву ніхто не знає успіху
питання забралися в гармату в архіві
збу душі на кишеню вигаданими наших
фіксуючого ладу
я казав і хоч орала ці добре перед
смерть та там просто провала нас по
центру не валиться донецька стояла розбито
техніка
принц , кабула на спиці форму вбивають
впав про них лікті прогули близько несіть
їх викликав і в результаті обміну уварити
на 14
олег тому юрій дим облизувався
подружишся і підсумував мишкою у луцьку
але це щось його не від нас.
можна сказати навіть напевно багато людей
займалося ще так почистила звели в
ранг у chery
восени хлопцям цих тату його нях
ви поливала вирізала їх роздирала
перевіряв та
у церкви до н. нам вдалося через
викликало нема дичини друга юрій а он і і
розписалася а у дайни закладеності тут
запалити сучки зад їх хто за провину в
друк провини